[Music]
the reason these pictures are important
to show how packed they are
somewhere close by that same weekend uh
there were about 150 150
uh people that were released without a
notice to appear
to me that's unprecedented how do you
release somebody to the country
without it just to appear
that's congressman henry clay our
democrat from texas let's bring in now
republican sender from that same state
john cornyn ranking member of the
judiciary committee's subcommittee on
immigration citizenship
and border safety good morning senator
you heard the congressman right there
at least 150 people at least he's
witnessed released
without even a notice to appear so what
we're seeing at our border is a flood of
migrants
who essentially are walking through a
revolving door in the front and out the
back
into the united states that's an open
border is it not
it is and uh you know it's an invitation
to the human smugglers who charge
roughly five thousand dollars ahead to
move people across the border into the
into the country and for people to
successfully make it here they call back
home
and say i made it you come on too and
this is the
very definition of losing control of our
border
uh congressman cuellar my friend from
laredo texas
a good democrat uh he's he's exactly
right
well go ahead well i was going to say uh
senator you know those images that uh
cuellar leaked yesterday
uh caused the customs and border
protection to release new video
today okay that's what came out
yesterday new video came out today that
we would like to look at
and what's interesting about it is it
shows another one of the kids uh
processing centers
if we can look at the video uh in donna
texas and also
in el paso and here's the video right
here and what's interesting in the
background
senator is chain-link fence that green
stuff back there
covers chain link fence you can see it
very clearly right there so
this administration has said these are
not kids in cages
but senator those are kids in the same
cages
that they referred to during the donald
trump years
well we all believe that children should
be treated humanely
and under these circumstances there's no
choice but to try to protect them
from some of the sex offenders or
criminal aliens or others that are mixed
in with the population
that are coming across our uncontrolled
border and so
i i you know we all share that goal to
treat them humanely but unfortunately
you can't treat them humanely when
they're packed in like sardines
because they're just so many of them
that that the border patrol can't
process them fast enough
not to mention the fact that the cartels
understand that when the border patrol
is off of the border
trying to process these children they're
not there to stop the
fentanyl the heroin the methamphetamine
the other drugs
when we talked to representative cuellar
earlier today he talked about the
frustration that so many people who live
in texas and arizona and these border
states
have with the fact that these policies
are being made in far away places in
washington d.c
and yet the people making these policies
joe biden
vice president kamala harris have not
come to the border since they changed
the trump era policies on immigration
here's a clip of vice president harris
being asked about when she was going to
come to the border
do you plan to visit the border
not today but
i have before and i'm sure i will again
she seems to think it's a laughing
matter i'm concerned not just with her
coming down but i know that you're
part of a delegation i believe there's a
large delegation of senators
coming to the border this week are they
going to get access are they going to be
able to have pictures or are they going
to be sent to some facility that
seems to be running okay better than
and and not really getting a real
picture of what is happening to the
people
um in these facilities well it is no
laughing matter and i wish
the vice president and president would
come to the border i'd be glad to
welcome them there and and uh so they
can learn what i've learned talking to
the experts the border patrol health and
human services
as well as the local officials and
stakeholders who are bearing the burden
of this open border policy of this
administration
and yes senator cruz and i are taking 13
of our colleagues from the senate to the
border as i've
done before to try to help them
understand
let them get exposed to the same sort of
expertise and advice that
that i have as i've been there as you
can imagine numerous occasions
but the border patrol is telling us that
you cannot build
enough facilities you cannot build
enough capacity
to keep up with the expected increase in
flow
of people coming across the border this
there's this
the green light is out and so far the
administration's sending no signals that
you won't be able to make it
successfully across all right senator
john cornyn of texas thank you for
getting up with us this morning senator
you bet